CAT ALLMAN: Hi.
I'm Cat Allman with
Google's Open Source team.
I'm here today with one of my
favorite colleagues, Jeremy
Allison of the Samba Project,
to tell you all about Samba.
Hi, Jeremy.
JEREMY ALLISON: Hi, Cat.
CAT ALLMAN: So starting in
general terms, elevator speech,
what is Samba?
JEREMY ALLISON: Samba is a
file print and authentication
server.
And that sounds incredibly
boring, because it is.
It's basically part
of the glue that
allows computers to
connect to each other.
Unlike the internet,
it's an older technology
that's designed for
local file sharing.
So rather than being somewhere,
and connecting to your Wi-Fi
and wondering where a printer
is, with the SMB technology
that Samba implements,
which is commonly
used by Windows clients, you
browse your local network
and you would print or get
access to local resources.
It's the technology used
behind the Microsoft's Active
Directory, if that helps.
CAT ALLMAN: You
mentioned Windows
and I always thought
Samba was all
about making Windows resources
available to everybody
else, and vice-versa.
JEREMY ALLISON: It's about
making Linux and Unix
machines export resources
to Windows clients.
But these days, SMB's actually
being quite widely adopted
by both Linux and Mac,
less so by Android,
although there are many
apps that will talk SMB.
So it's less of a
Windows only technology,
and there people actually who
use SMB going between Unix
to Unix, which is very
strange from where it started.
CAT ALLMAN: Yes, it is.
How many people are
touched by Samba?
I mean, is this something
that only developers use?
Or is it under the hood?
JEREMY ALLISON: I like to
refer to it as plumbing, which
is nice because it means I'm
the equivalent of a plumber,
with a plunger
removing blockages.
It's the technology that's
used behind many, many
network-attached
storage devices.
As I like to joke, if
you go in to Fry's,
or any other electronics
store, and you
buy a disk that's advertised
as network-attached storage,
something that you'd
be able to connect
to over your wireless LAN
or over your wired LAN, that
stores your music
medium or whatever,
I like to say if it
costs under $10,000,
it's got Samba inside it.
It's actually used in a
great number of products.
CAT ALLMAN: Roku, set-top
boxes, things like that?
JEREMY ALLISON:
Some set-top boxes,
but they mainly use
the client piece,
because the set-top boxes
want to access the resources
and the client piece
is actually built
into Linux, which is commonly
used for those boxes.
Samba itself, the project, is
more of the server-side piece,
which is what runs on the
network-attached storage that
exports to the clients.
It's more like Netgear,
Western Digital,
many of the
network-attached storage.
Blanking on a lot of
there names right now.
It's also started
to be used in what's
called cloud gateway storage.
People who want to get access to
resources stored in the cloud,
but they want to use
local applications that
think they're talking
to a local file
but are actually talking
to cloud storage.
What quite a few
companies are doing now
is using Samba as a gateway.
So they have a device
that they will sell you
that actually pretends to
be a local file server,
but is actually accessing
resources that exist out
in the internet cloud.
CAT ALLMAN: When
did Samba start?
How did you come up with this?
JEREMY ALLISON:
It wasn't just me.
It was actually
originally created
by myself and a friend of mine,
Andrew Tridgell in Australia.
And it's actually older
than the Linux kernel,
or around the same age.
It's a very old,
established project.
It's about 20, 21 years old.
And essentially, he
was a PhD student
who was trying to find
something else to do rather
than these studies and
writing his thesis.
And I was actually
working for a company that
needed to share files between
Windows and Unix machines
and was completely fed up
with the only thing that
was being sold at
the time, which
was PCNFS, which was horrible.
Essentially, we banded
together and started
to develop something better
that talked to the Windows
protocols.
And it attracted more developers
and has grown from there,
really.
CAT ALLMAN: How many developers
are, generally speaking,
contributing to the project?
JEREMY ALLISON: Well, it varies.
We have a lot of
alumni people who've
come through, worked
on the project,
and gone on to better
and brighter things.
Many of them actually
work at Google.
And we have people
like myself, who
stayed working on the project
for its entire lifetime,
and also [INAUDIBLE] who
has a German company that
supports Samba.
I would say there
are probably about 10
to 15 active developers, so it's
actually quite a small project.
There are many, many of the
peripheral developers-- people
doing testing, people
doing QA, people
who come in to fix a specific
bug that's really bugging them
and then go away again because
they've got the fix in they
need.
CAT ALLMAN: And Samba's
your full-time time job here
at Google?
JEREMY ALLISON: 80%.
So most Googlers have 20% time.
I have 80% time, but 20% of the
time I'm doing things for you.
CAT ALLMAN: Nice, nice.
JEREMY ALLISON: Appearing
on these interviews,
these kinds of things.
CAT ALLMAN: I understand you
just released a new version.
What, three weeks ago?
JEREMY ALLISON: Actually,
the big new version
came out about a year or so
ago, and that was Samba 4.
We release versions
fairly regularly,
so unless it's a
major release, it's
mainly bug fixes of
interest to people
who are following the project
and need specific things fixed.
But the big new release
we did, which was Samba 4,
was our first implementation
of an active directory domain
controller.
So for the first
time, you can actually
have Windows clients talking to
and cooperating with a domain
controller, an active
directory domain
controller, full
active directory, that
is not made by Microsoft.
And it will inter-operate with
Microsoft active directory
domain controllers
and, in fact, Microsoft
have worked with us actually
fixed some bugs on the Windows
client side to make
this work for us.
I'm pretty happy about that.
That's a really cool new thing.
CAT ALLMAN: Are you looking
for new contributors
to the project?
JEREMY ALLISON: Always.
As with most open source
projects, we're desperate.
We could always do
with more contributors.
The kind of things
that we need are,
while Samba's written in C, so
it's kind of an old project,
so if you really want to do
sort of down-and-dirty, very
hard technical work, Samba
is the place to do it.
There's a lot of very
hard, very technical work
that needs doing.
Lots of bugs that need fixing.
You can learn about very
many core technologies
by working on Samba--
security technologies,
file sharing technologies,
how to do encryption,
all these kind of things.
But we also need people
who can help document it,
because like most
open source projects,
it's terribly documented.
We have a record for
the longest man page,
I think something like 300
or 500 pages, all of which
are configuration options,
many of which are confusing.
What would really help is
people who could write,
technical writers, essentially.
And also people who can do QA,
quality assurance, and also
people who could help market
it, people who can help
explain how it works,
write up scenarios.
We have a wiki that
describes how it's used,
and how it can be used.
It's so big and
it's so flexible,
it's hard to describe
in a short time.
But the great
reason for doing so
is that I get pinged
regularly by companies looking
for engineers who
have Samba experience.
If you're looking
for a job, and you're
in the technical
industry, working on Samba
is a very, very
good way to get one.
CAT ALLMAN: OK, so
where do people go?
JEREMY ALLISON: Samba.org
is our main website.
And everything is under there.
There's the wiki.
There's the git repository.
There's all the mailing lists.
To get started I would recommend
joining the Samba mailing list.
And that's mainly
for users of Samba.
If you want to get a
little more technical,
we have a Samba
technical mailing list.
And then we have a
Samba-technical IRC channel
on freenode.net, which is the
main open source IRC server.
CAT ALLMAN: Anything
else you want
to tell people
about the project?
I assume it's fun
or you wouldn't
have spent a long
time doing this.
JEREMY ALLISON:
It's amazingly fun.
The thing about it
is it keeps changing,
and this is why I
still work on it,
this is why I still find
it fun and interesting.
You can work on as simple things
as parsing configuration files,
very, very simple bug
fixes, all the way up
to research level projects
that are funded by IBM to do
with distributed clustered
file storage technologies
and synchronizing file
systems between many hundreds
of machines.
And it's all there,
all there in the code.
I won't say it's available
in small bite size chunks,
but everything is there.
This is the wonderful thing,
and the wonderful thing
about most open source, is
that by working on this stuff
you can see code that is
used in the real world.
If you're a student, and
you're looking at this stuff,
you're not working
on toy projects.
You're not working
on tiny things
that your professors
have assigned
to solve trivial problems.
You're working on real
problems that real engineers
are using in real
world solutions.
You're actually seeing
the code, the glue
that holds the world together.
And it's a real thing.
You can make a difference.
You can actually contribute
and change it yourself.
And that's just intoxicating.
That's kind of
how I got started.
It's like, I send the
patches over here,
and they turn up in the product.
It's amazing.
You can actually change
the world with this stuff.
CAT ALLMAN: I'm totally
stealing that line about this
is the glue that holds
the world together.
JEREMY ALLISON: Fair enough.
It's absolutely compelling.
If you're an
engineer, or if you're
interested in
technical things, I
can't imagine anything
more fun to do.
CAT ALLMAN: Fantastic.
Thank you, Jeremy.
JEREMY ALLISON: Thank you, Cat.
CAT ALLMAN: And thank all
of you for joining us.
I urge you to go to
samba.org and check it out.
And if it ignites even a
tiny fraction of the passion
that Jeremy has for
Samba, I'd encourage
you to consider
becoming a contributor.
JEREMY ALLISON:
Thank you very much.
CAT ALLMAN: Bye.